mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 ces
sauveteurs qui enchaîne dès le début de
la matinée de lundi exercice au niveau
de la baignoire de joséphine enfants
soient sont contraints d'intervenir en
situation bien réelle
ces personnes debout sur leurs pas
d'elle qui se déplace à la rame se sont
involontairement éloignés de leur
trajectoire
elles sont prises en charge par les
hommes de la snsm et a eu des grêles va
s'élever dans l'europe
sur la fin on était un peu en difficulté
puisque c'est facile fatiguant sur toute
la longueur
donc voilà on heureusement qu'il y avait
des sauveteurs tout près donc
on a profité d'une puissance pour faire
signer déjà allé le copiant qui passait
voilà le réseau l'équipe est venue
je cherchais situation qui prouve donc
l'importance des différentes unités dans
la zone de fort de france 2 castle rock
du marin et du françois des bénévoles
prête à intervenir rapidement
à la moindre alerte nous sommes tous des
bénévoles c'est une passion nous avons
tous des métiers et des fonctions
différentes dans la dans le privé et
nous sommes tous portés par la même
chose c'est-à-dire se courir les
les personnes qui seraient en difficulté
en mer et passion oui parce que
si on n'aime pas ça on tient pas
longtemps
cette deuxième édition de la journée
nationale des sauveteurs en mer est une
occasion de démontrer à l'ensemble de la
communauté maritime le savoir-faire des
différentes unités
elle s'entraîne régulièrement chaque
semaine quelles que soient les
conditions climatiques
on s'entraîne pour ça on s'entraîne en
conditions réelles pour pour parer à
toute éventualité pour que les jeunes
soient de plus en plus automatiques et
que que ça se passe de mieux en mieux le
jour j je dirais que c'est capital
aujourd'hui d'avoir ce genre de
personnes sur l'eau ne serait ce que
pour la sécurité des professionnels et
des plaisanciers afin de pouvoir gérer
la chose au mieux une présence en mer
est essentielle
salué par le mil snsm aujourd'hui tous
les usagers de la martinique de france
et de navarre était invité à parcourir
un mille nautique à midi